6:00 a.m. at Berlin's Authority for
Health and Social Affairs again refugees
in the hundreds are waiting they include
Maya de contas aya and her family they
got up early this morning to get a good
place in line we've been sleeping in a
gymnasium for a month now I've taken my
children to a hospital they just aren't
getting better my little one is still
sick because everything's so dirty here
temperatures outside are hovering at the
freezing point at least a few heated
tents are available segregated between
men and women
Maya de contas iya fled Syria as the war
approached her home now she's waiting
for an appointment to get a place to
stay we want to learn German we already
had a tutor but I can't register at a
school because we have small children
and constant appointments in court and
the welfare office I need an apartment
to get some peace with the kids and
study once inside the building more
waiting caseworkers can process some 230
asylum seekers daily but on any given
day more than 800 can show up in the
past year eighty thousand asylum seekers
came to Berlin the city's bureaucracy
can't keep up
it's trying to make the transition find
qualified personnel optimizing workflows
setting up new structures all within
weeks is a continuing process we're
working hard on a main goal now is
ensuring that no one with an appointment
is turned away anymore this family
waited two and a half months for theirs
the people who came here from elsewhere
say it was better than in Berlin when I
get my residence permit I'm not staying
in Berlin next to the office volunteers
try to help they're still having to
shoulder tasks that should be done by
the state if Berlin can't cope and the
problems are so big then we really have
to ask why they didn't declare a
disaster situation like they did in
Munich in the frankfurt area it's
something we keep repeating because it's
so obvious why don't they do it here
Berlin still hesitates to declare a
disaster situation an expensive move
that the broke city can ill afford